hello
my name is liam gallagher and thanks
very much for attending my webinar today
i'm going to talk to you today about a
particular new
exciting initiative collaborative cancer
research center rest predict
and how we're applying this particular
approaches relevant assistance medicine
towards
developing better treatment strategies
and also new diagnostic options within
the breast cancer context
so just a bit of an introduction around
breast cancer just going to give you
some kind of context behind the center
i'm speaking to you today from dublin
ireland but you could you know if you
look at the stats within ireland they're
quite similar to what's seen in the uk
and the us
we have this issue now at the moment
that one in ten women face a chance of
developing breast cancer within their
lifetime
and then if you look
in terms of the worldwide incidence of
breast cancer we see that the global
incidence of this disease is increasing
some of this is due to improvements in
screening and also lifestyle factors
but we know that from 2012 it's
predicted to increase from 1.7 million
women with
breast cancer up to over two and a half
million uh in 2035.
now we know that the news is not all
that bad because due to i suppose
advances in screening surgery
various different therapeutic options
including a conventional classical
chemotherapy
hormone therapy but also the development
of new and more exciting targeted
therapies
mortality due to breast cancer is
decreasing
such that we have uh if patients present
with localized disease they have a very
good chance of long-term survival
now we still have an issue with patients
which present with
distant or
distant metastases in terms of the poor
survival rates of these patients
but in conclusion most women diagnosed
with breast cancer now survive
and this is really uh provides a context
behind that we it's been becoming more
important that we tailor treatments
and also avoid some unnecessary side
effects of scientific treatment
now we know that research has made a
significant impact in terms of our
understanding of some of the risk
factors associated with breast cancer
and some of these are well known both to
the scientists but also to the lay
public
we know that for example obesity poor
diet alcohol lack of exercise and
hormone exposure are changeable factors
which can actually impact or impinge on
breast cancer risk
we're also familiar with the concept of
particular susceptibility genes or
factors or mutations particularly genes
like bracket 1 and bracket 2 and other
similar genes which predispose or prefer
a higher risk of getting breast cancer
obviously as a person ages
the risk of cancer in general increases
and these factors are obviously
unchangeable in the main
alongside these knowledge about risk
factors we really have come to
understand a lot about the biology of
breast cancer via a variety of different
approaches
uh sequencing approaches or various
other ohmic approaches
for example we know a lot about the
different subtypes of breast cancer
the relative response rates to different
treatments
we know we have a lot of new biomarkers
which can be used in a breast cancer
context so there's a lot out there in
terms of the in terms of our arsenal to
deal with breast cancer
and this is just captured in the next
slide where we've really charted some of
the key seminal steps
uh throughout
just over the last century approximately
or a bit longer
for example
if we look at just before the uh
end of the 19th century we have
essentially the development of radical
prostectomy
again around that time period
george beats in in scotland performed
the first wolverectomy as a treatment
option
and removal of the ovaries as a
treatment option for breast cancer
now in terms of the first impact in
terms of drug treatment we can actually
look at
the development of tamoxifen
really
this drug has had a major impact in
terms of
uh
particularly in an er positive or issue
receptor positive context in terms of
targeting breast cancer it's probably
one would argue one of the most
successful anti-cancer drugs that has
been developed to
date again in the
mid to late 80s we have the
really the development of more targeted
agents again tamoxifen is an example of
a targeted drug but also we have as well
as a poster child of targeted drugs
herceptin which targets the epidermal
growth factor receptor her2 which is
over expressed in approximately a third
of breast cancers and these particular
substitute group of breast cancers have
a very poor outcome in terms of their
treatment response and due to
development of these
what are called her2 targeting drugs
like herceptin their actual outcome of
patients with this type of subtype of
breast cancer has dramatically improved
in recent years
again
when we look at the impact of the ohmic
era on breast cancer
it has
made a significant change in terms of
how we actually look at breast cancer
we've we have these classical
subtypes of breast cancer which can be
divided into eastern receptor positive
breast cancer
triple negative breast cancer which are
devoid of the eastern receptor protein
progesterone receptor and her2 and then
heritage positive breast cancer where
they overexpress this her2 protein and
again during the 90s and also
in the early 2000s
there was a lot of work with the on
defining new molecular subtypes of
breast cancer via gene expression
profiling and some of these
discoveries have now been translated
into new diagnostic tools which are used
clinically for example like archetype dx
and narrow print
alongside that we've had a development
of lots of other targeted agents for
example we have
agents which are targeting particular
kinases etc
now when we look at the
i suppose the tips of different types of
agents which are used to treat breast
cancer
still within the as well the arsenal in
terms of dealing with breast cancer we
have classical chemotherapy
generally when we talk about targeted
agents are used in combination with
classical chemotherapy
what i just indicated here is really
just a kind of various different agents
which can be used to target the her2
protein this could be the prototypical
uh monoclonal antibody transgenic map or
herceptin and then also you have these
variety of other agents like tdm1 which
is this new antibody drug conjugate or
you have low molecular weight compounds
not an antibody such as lapatinib which
can actually
inhibit a tyrosine kinase activity of
this receptor
also as i indicated before that the um
sorry
also as i've indicated
before hormone therapy plays an import
very important role in terms of the
treatment of
breast cancer
and we have a variety of different
agents including the kind of i suppose a
standard rare tamoxifen but we also have
aromatase inhibitors which can be used
to deplete the supply of estrogens
systemically
now alongside these very widely used
agents we have also new agents starting
to be approved targeted agents for
example everolimus which is an mtor
inhibitor has recently been improved for
the treatment of breast cancer
particularly breast cancers which
essentially are resistant or have had a
relapse on
endocrine therapy
there was an approval by the fda for the
use of avastin for breast cancer which
has been rescinded recently because of
lack of efficacy but again there are
there is still an interest potentially
in the use of angiogenesis inhibitors to
to combat breast cancer
again what i've indicated at the bottom
is we have this slide there's really
there's a whole slew of agents out there
in
clinical development
really uh covering a variety of
different molecular targets which are
being tested in breast cancer and some
of these for example what would assume
will be approved over the coming years
i've just highlighted a couple of these
and for example there's a big interest
now out in agents which can actually
target cdk four and six like this agent
from pfizer pablo ciclib there's also a
big interest reading agents which can
actually target um defects in dna repair
such as the carb inhibitors
so i've kind of painted that with a
brief picture about the kind of
background behind breast cancer and i
suppose it's important to describe
really
why do we need a collaborative cancer
research center
and so an important
document that might be of use to you if
you're interested in a breast cancer
arena
is a gap analysis that was performed by
the uk charity breast cancer campaign
and they brought together just under you
know 80-100 investigators with
specialist expertise in either oncology
basic science translation research with
an interest in breast cancer really to
look at the critical gaps and
translational priorities required are
important issues in terms of that are
still outstanding in the context of
breast cancer
and some of the conclusions from this
document which was published in breast
cancer research in 2003
um
sorry one second
was that we need to really improve our
resources towards breast cancer research
we need to develop a fully cohesive and
collaborative infrastructure to support
research
we need access to appropriate and
well-annotated clinical material
we need to encourage collaboration
between researchers in different
scientific fields
and also improve clinical trial methods
to better meet the complexity of modern
treatment options for patient benefit
so this leads into
this initiative which i direct called
rest predict
and this uh this program is a
funded by
a major
charity within ireland called the irish
cancer society it's the main charity
which forms cancer research
and it's the first of what they term a
collaborative cancer research center
it's a virtual center where we bring
together essentially researchers from
multiple different institutions around
ireland plus a cooperative oncology
research group that is currently a
clinical trials activity
and really to work in a collaborative
research environment it's not really
about
a bricks and mortar it's about the
individuals working together in a
collaborative team
so this program kicked off in october of
last year
and we have funding really for a
five-year program we've just completed
the first year of this program and i'm
going to give you some highlights uh
from the former first year
it's the first of these new
collaborative cancer research centers
which are going to be funded by the
irish cancer society over the coming
years
this particular one is focused on breast
cancer and the other subsequent centers
might be focused on different um
cancers from different origins or maybe
focus on a mechanism of disease
and really the goal behind these centers
is really to bring and this one in
particular is to bring together cancer
researchers and we obviously have an
interest in researchers with an interest
in breast cancer on various different
disciplines around ireland with a common
goal of improving the outlook of breast
cancer patients both in ireland and
worldwide
and so this center has three main themes
or components
there is a a translational research
component where we as well come up with
new discoveries from the bench
try to bring these forward and look at a
path of physiological relevance in
clinical tissues for example
result there's also a clinical trial
component or intersection with a
clinical trial component and another
important perspective is also take on
board information at a population based
level
and again
our programs are structured such that we
also have intersection across these
thematic areas
i suppose if we look at a collaborative
center why we would do it and and where
the context behind it is really again we
want to bring together a group of
talented researchers to tackle a number
of key issues relating to breast cancer
we want to really maximize use of the
resources there's no point in us for
example or multiple different
institutions
really
for example buying the same piece of
equipment but you know and
wasting money on a multiple piece of
equipment but not really maximizing
those resources so really we want to
encourage researchers to share those
resources and expertise
uh we're really needs driven we really
feel want to focus on the needs of
patients
there's also a training mission within
the center where we organize um
various different seminars and workshops
and again we want to really bring
together specialists for example
particularly in the area of
computational biology bioinformatics
mathematical modeling in conjunction
with the practitioners bday surgeons
oncologists pathologists and really kind
of um
maximize the interdisciplinarity behind
our center
as i mentioned avoid this duplication of
resources
so who are we we're essentially a group
of 20 investigators dotted around
ireland in the background here to map
real estate of ireland
but what i'm just indicating here are
the 10 pis which are involved and then
on the right hand side are just a list
of some of the other funded
investigators in total we are 20
investigators
from six academic institutions around
ireland and that's indicated in the
bottom right i won't go into detail
you can actually look at a website in
terms of what are the institutions i
want to pilot one particular partner in
addition to these six academic
institutions which are primarily the
main universities and other academic
institutions in ireland there's also a
important cooperative group icorg
which is a performs clinical trials and
oncology space
across
both the republic of ireland and
northern ireland and really all of the
practicing oncologists be they medical
oncologists surgeons
really have signed up to an integrated
program for delivering new therapies to
to cancer patients within ireland and so
our program really leverages that
important resource
so just in a bit more detail about the
research that's taking place within the
program
and just to set the context we know that
breast cancer is not just one disease
we know that for example patients
they may present with similar clinical
features they could for example two
patients could be er positive
her2 negative they both may receive
hormone therapy and chemotherapy
but we know that for example those
patients can diverge in terms of their
responses in patient a and patient b and
this is indicated here in this in this
scanning concept where we have two
patients which obviously have diverged
in terms of their treatment outcome
we also have this issue of differences
between for example the primary tumor
that may be in the breast and also the
the tumor that has disseminated either
locally or at distant sites
there's a change in the biological
characteristics of that tumor in terms
of for example their ability of these
tumor cells to move and survive in
circulation and then also
recite and and survive in different
areas and so we're kind of interested in
exploring
while these biological differences
and then obviously recently over the
last number of years people have become
very interested looking at more closely
within the tumor itself and looking at
heterogeneity in terms of different cell
populations
and different molecular subsets within
those
tumors
and this is important context in terms
of
treatment for example we could have a
certain subpopulation which is
inherently resistant to particular types
of treatment and it could be present at
a very low level
or low proportion within the tumor mass
and while we may get overtly a good
treatment response in the bulk of the
tumor that residual low subpopulation
may actually survive and then go on to
contribute to remission or relapse of
the tumor over time
so that's the context we have diversity
at multiple different levels either
between the patient between the tumor
and within the tumor
and what we've seen is that we've had a
lot of really fantastic advances over
the last number of years we have great
information at a molecular level
and really what we want to do now is
harness this new data to redefine how we
treat breast cancer with the ultimate
goal of more precise therapy
and again we have an issue in terms of
the complexity of types of data that
we're dealing with
for example working with gene expression
data proteomic data mutation data really
what we want to do is combine this
information in a particular way that we
can actually add value to the current
treatment paradigms which are already
present
and this derives this new concept of
systems medicine where we actually can
integrate data at multiple levels to
really
address this clinical need
another key context behind the center is
really tackle some of the key factors
which are hampering progress in breast
cancer research and again it's one of
the areas that was highlighted in that
gap analysis document was really i'll
come back in a subsequent slide
so what i'm indicating here is really
this this concept of leveraging data to
personalize therapy
so as i indicated that center has three
main components we have a translational
component a clinical component in a
population based component all
gravitating around a research core
one thing to note that i when i talk
about this again this cooperative
oncology group icorg which is carrying
out clinical trials within ireland
they've essentially recruited over the
last 15 years approximately 7000 cancer
patients in clinical trials of those and
very significant proportion of those are
within the area of breast cancer so we
have a rich resource of
clinical trial material that we can
actually get access to to carry out
research
which i'll come back to later on
so again when we look at
dissecting
breast cancer at different levels
we obviously have an interest in looking
at the
gene alterations at a for example a
mutational level expression level of
protein expression differences but it's
important to be able to map this type of
molecular data with robust clinical
information but also combine this or
marry this with what's seen at a
population based level
so it's important that when we generate
data that we can actually integrate it
into a centralized database so where we
can actually look at these different
aspects
again
from this following this data
integration we want to come up with new
diagnostic options and therapeutic
options that then can be subsequently
validated within our patient populations
i mentioned this concept um
earlier which is really this one of the
barriers to
breast cancer research but also other
forms of cancer research is really
access to relevant biological materials
particularly
specimens from patients
which have relapsed on disease you know
it's
sometimes it's quite quite difficult to
get access to
metastatic material fresh metastatic
material where you can actually carry
out robust investigation
so i've indicated here on the schematic
is really looking at the various
different stages that a female with
breast cancer could go through for
example you may have
healthy women which can be profiled into
a
lower high risk
but really what we focus on is really in
the context of patients when they
present with primary cancer
can we for example assess
the
molecular profile of that tumor to
determine what's the most appropriate
treatment a person may have initially a
remission and unfortunately may
relapse
or even initially present with
metastatic disease and this is where it
becomes very important to be able to
compare the primary tumor versus
the metastatic lesions
and this is one of the goals behind one
of our work packages within breast
predict
as part of our center and this brings in
the population-based level aspect is
that
we're really interested in looking at
the impact of lifestyle factors but also
exposure to other medicines and
for other commonly prescribed medicines
for example aspirins and statins in
terms of the impact of breast cancer
outcome and response to treatment
and so we actually have ethical approval
now
we're rolling this out on an all ireland
basis all country bases to really gain
this type of information from all breast
cancer patients within ireland
so we have eight major cancer treating
centers within ireland all of these are
on board for this particular program
so some of the questions that we're
answering in our research programs is as
i mentioned that we we know that a
significant proportion of women actually
take various different prescribed drugs
prior to their breast cancer diagnosis
and we weren't really interested in what
is the impact of those drug exposures on
the breast cancer that they actually
eventually get and so what's really the
impact of commonly prescribed drugs
on
outcome and responsive treatment
another key interest within the center
is really looking at how do tumors
evolve breast cancers evolve over time
in response to treatment
and again one of the kind of key
interests out there again as i mentioned
we have a huge arsenal out there of
different therapeutic options in breast
cancer we have various different
classical chemotherapies but also new
and exciting
targeted agents and the key question is
how do we effectively combine these
together to get maximum impact
and we're interested really in combining
both in silico and network modeling
approaches to come up with optimal
combination strategies but also to use
very sophisticated in vitro and vivo
models to actually come up with optimal
combinations that will actually then be
translated and tested in a human context
so we have five main goals within our
center the first is really to provide a
consolidated national breast cancer body
banking database and a lot of work has
already taken place
by a number of different investigators
within breast predict to generate a
robust biobank we want to layer around
that a really sophisticated databasing
infrastructure that we can actually pull
in data from multiple different aspects
and then what's with this is our kind of
core of materials and information
in the context of breast cancer within
ireland
and around us we have four research
orientated and work packages which are
asking specific questions and one of
these is looking at the impact of
aspirins and statins taken prior to
breast cancer diagnosis in terms of the
impact on an outcome
another question is looking at another
work package is looking at how do tumors
evolve in terms of response to endocrine
therapy and her2 targeted therapies
again as i mentioned we have a work
package focused on modeling the best
combinations of anti-cancer therapies
particularly combinations of targeted
agents
and then we also have a work package
focused on diagnostics i'm going to
elaborate on each of these programs in
the subsequent slides
so the first work package which is the
central consolidation work package it's
really about building a comprehensive
infrastructure and also capacity
building this is led by professor leone
young who's based in the royal college
of surgeons in ireland and
professor young has a huge amount of
expertise and really building a robust
biobanks particularly at the college of
surgeons
but also she has actually made a lot of
efforts now to expand beyond that to
other centers around ireland
and the deputy lead for dissent and this
activity is professor michael curran
who's a
very prominent surgeon based in galway
and the west of ireland
and has also kind of led similar efforts
to establish biobanking activities
within that region of ireland and again
they're they're joined by other members
within work package one we need to
provide a very comprehensive platform
for investigation
so the various different sub-components
of this activity is really to
provide a resource a tissue and blood
from best breast cancer patients both
that primary diagnosis but also
importantly during treatment so we're
providing really a longitudinal resource
that we can actually use for downstream
experimentation
another key feature behind it is there's
obviously a big interest now in the
cancer community to working with more
relevant and vivo models particularly
the use of patient-derived xenograph
models we're using two complementary
models and generating a variety of these
and as part of the center
for example we're taking primary tumor
material but also material from
metastatic lesions to create pdx models
but also looking at combinations of
tumor cells but also patient-derived
stromal cells
and looking at the impact of these on
within individual models
nicely around that we also have very
comprehensive molecular imaging
platforms to actually
profile
what happens to these tumors in terms of
their
growth rates their metastatic potential
but also their response to treatment
as i mentioned we have a component
around building a national breast cancer
database and the key aspect behind this
is being able to pull in data for
example from the national cancer
registry in ireland the national
prescribing databases drug prescribing
databases breast cancer screening data
but also data that's resonant within
various different pathology departments
and one kind of i suppose more blue
skies aspect behind this program is
obviously we have an important resource
in terms of
emerging molecular data that's going to
be generated in subsequent work packages
but also we have this clinical data
that's going to be present within that
patient set there's really an
opportunity to combine this information
into developing virtual patient models
that can be used underlying
so work package 2 is focused on
uncovering pathways from population drug
exposures to breast cancer outcomes
and this particular work package is led
by professor kathleen bennett who's
based in trinity college dublin and
kathleen is a
acknowledged pharmacal epidemiologist
and the deputy lead for this program is
dr annette byrne from the royal college
of surgeons in ireland and dr barn is a
leader in the area of
modeling of cancer in people within
small animal models
and so
one of the components is that we
we really want to focus on
this link that is seen in terms of
exposure
pre-diagnostically our patients breast
cancer patients before they get their
diagnosis of breast cancer looking at
the potential impact of aspirins aspirin
intake in terms of their outcome
and so approximately we predict about
one quarter of
patients
breast cancer patients would have taken
low dose aspirin which is actually
prescription only within ireland
prior to their breast cancer diagnosis
and
investigators within the team have
actually published a paper in cancer
research which has shown that aspirin
seems to have a protective impact in
terms of reducing um
the
the aggressive characteristics of the
breast cancer that's presented and when
when patients actually take low dose
aspirin prior to their diagnosis
so one thing that we're kind of keen to
do is really
expand beyond this study
and actually look at for example the
impact of known cancer driving mutations
particularly looking at the impact of
pi3 kinase mutations on this effect
and also look at
this pathway at a bit more mechanistic
level looking for example at members of
the cox2 family and prostaglandin
pathway
to try to understand
why we're seeing this potentially
protect protective effect
alongside this kind of
i suppose molecular pathology studies
we're also
trying to dissect the mechanism of
action of aspirin
within more relevant and vivo models
and
one of the concepts is that aspirin may
have an impact on lymph angiogenesis
and so one of the kind of key goals
within this work package is to establish
robust animal models combined with
imaging approaches to look at the impact
of aspirin on lymphangiogenesis
and again as i mentioned this particular
work package
is focused on both aspirants and statins
and we have some data from our lab
showing that
when we look at the expression of the
one of the drug targets for statins hmg
choreo reductase at a protein expression
level within breast tumors
high expression of that particular
enzyme
this drug target for staffing seems to
be associated with a
modified response to endocrine therapy
and so we're very interested in really
seeing if this is
really relevant this observation we've
seen in breast cancer tissues is
relevant in the population-based level
and that's an area that we're actually
exploring
within
the central model
work package three is looking at the
impact of our or looking at the
evolution of tumors
during therapy
uh particularly in the context of
endocrine therapy and
therapies which target her2 protein
this particular activity is led by a
professor brian hennessey
who's a medical oncologist based in the
royal college of surgeons in ireland and
the deputy lead is professor dex
higgins who
is a kind of world famous
bioinformatician who developed for
example the sequels alignment program
cluster
so in a variety of different
kind of concept studies
what we're doing is leveraging the
resources that we have within the this
icork our clinical trials infrastructure
within ireland
where we can actually look at patients
in a longitudinal manner looking at the
how they evolve during treatment at a
molecular level
and so what we've done is we've
identified a number of different
clinical trials within the portfolio of
icorg where we have patient samples at
various different intervals during
treatment for example before
before new adjuvant treatment at the
point of surgery
at point of relapse etc
and what we're doing is we're getting
we've gotten access to those materials
and we're performing multi-pronged ohmic
assessment for example looking at
whole exome changes at a mutational
level within the dna looking at
transphobic alterations using rna
sequencing and then also looking at
protein expression and signaling changes
using reverse phase protein ray
technology
and again we have a lot of expertise in
really kind of marrying these two are
these various different types of data
sets together
with a dna alterations rna alterations
or protein expression alterations
and we want to really
come up with really i suppose novel
pathway alterations which
maybe explain for example either
preferential sensitivity to these types
of treatments or resistance or emerge
emerging resistance
so following these discovery and
studies which are still ongoing we also
have a program of downstream extensive
validation where we're going to look at
really extrapolating these findings and
a much broader set of patient samples
really to bring these observations
closer to a clinical implementation
work package 4 is really focused on this
concept of combining novel agents
together
to really come up with
novel therapy combinations
based on a more sophisticated
understanding of the biology of breast
cancer rather than just some empirical
mishmash of combinations or drugs that
you might use
this activity is led by a noted medical
oncologist in ireland professor john
crown
who's based in university college dublin
and dublin city university as well as
saint vincent's university hospital and
the deputy lead is professor water
culture director of the conway institute
and also systems biology ireland
so this particular
work package has three main components
which i'm going to outline here the
first is really to develop and utilize a
computational modeling framework
where we can actually link this ohmic
data for example data coming from this
work package tree
which i previously mentioned but also
external data that's already out there
there's a slew of
ohmic data and other similar data set
out there in the breast cancer context
that we can actually leverage
with
various different signal transduction
models which actually been developed
within the context of systems biology
ireland
and the idea is really to use this
information to really come up at an
silicon level with novel druggable
nodes which can then be subsequently
tested
experimentally within the lab using in
vitro and and then following that in
vivo models using
uh quote gene knock-down technologies
but also
therapeutic agents
alongside this computation modeling
framework we also have a plan we have
ongoing activities to really perform
robust functional screening
where we use various different
combinations of drugs and
libraries of si rnas or short terpene
nuclear rna to knock down genes of
interest
in essentially synthetic lethality
screens in various different model
systems to come up with novel
combinations
so we have both a modeling concept and
also a functional screening
aspect
so along these more kind of generic
broad-based approaches we have some very
targeted projects where we're actually
going with already kind of known
uh druggable entities and looking at
specific combinations
we're also looking at targeting mutant
53 using specific agents which can
actually
change the properties of mutant 53
converted into more wall type form and
then also we have a specific basic
research program program looking at
epigenetic silencing of
the p16 gene
so the last work package is looking at
kind of diagnostic implications
this work is led by professor joachim
pran who's based in the college of
surgeons
and also the deputy lead is professor
lorena driscoll who's a kind of leading
investigator emerging investigator
within trinity college dublin
and so this program has four different
aspects
the first actually is looking at um
apoptotic signatures so professors
friends group has actually spent a lot
of work really modeling various
different components within the
apoptosis signaling pathway
using a systems modeling approach and
he's shown in a colorectal cancer
context by by measuring essentially a
small number of components within the
apoptosis signaling pathway
he can actually come up with a his group
can actually come up with a predictor of
inherent
human sensitivity or chemo resistance so
he's shown this concept
uh using clinical tissues from
colorectal cancer patients and one of
the guilds behind the center is really
to validate a similar concept or a
similar approach within breast cancer
professor o'driscoll has put down a lot
of work really on looking at circulating
nucleic acids particularly micrornas but
also more conventional messenger rnas
within cancer patients this work has
also been done by professor uh karen and
uh dr wilson with warren galway
and there's a big interest in really
using these types of circulating nucleic
acids either free circulating nucleic
acids or ones which which are for
example bound within exosomes as
biomarkers of response to treatment
professor leonie young in the college of
surgeons has a huge wealth of expertise
in looking at molecular determinants of
response to endocrine therapy
and she has a particular problem where
she's identified a very interesting
putative mark of endocrine resistance
that she does she she is bringing
forward at a further level of technical
validation within the center
and the last program here within this
work package is led by professor
rosemarie o'connor in university college
cork
and she has really a huge amount of
expertise in igf signaling and she's
identified a really a very interesting
signature which may hold potential in
the breast cancer context we're working
very closely with her to really
translate this observation from the
basic science and into more clinical
context
so as i mentioned we've really been in
existence for a year
we've uh really been very successful i
think in establishing this this network
of
20
leading investigators in the breast
cancer field in ireland the actual
funding behind the irish cancer society
from the irish cancer has really
provided
an additional over 30 individuals or phd
students post doctoral fellows research
nurses and other staff so an extra over
30 individuals combined with those 20
investigators really create a team of
over 50 people working towards a common
agenda
to tackle
specific issues relating to breast
cancer
within that year we've published 12
research articles within prominent
cancer focused journals
we've also published various different
review articles
we've organized a variety of we've
established new collaborations and we're
actually open for collaboration with
with different partners around the world
we've all also organized various
different uh national
and
discrete seminars and also bigger
workshops
we've also enrolled a number of
different patients within various
different clinical trials
and we also have really greatly
accelerated the number of specimens that
can be used for translational research
in addition to these kind of core
activities we've also been able to
leverage additional funding from other
organizations both nationally and
internationally
that's what the key part of the center
is really because this is we receive
funding from a charity it's very
important that we communicate
our work to the public because they're
providing the resources for our research
and so we've actually spent a lot of
effort really kind of publicizing uh our
efforts and communicating these
the
scientific advances to the public
so we have a breast predict website
which i i'll indicate at the end of my
presentation and i would encourage you
to look at that if you're interested in
more details
uh this is just an indication of the
types of workshops we've organized over
the last year
and again as i mentioned we've published
these a variety of different articles
over the last year i'm going to
highlight just a couple of these just
will provide a bit more detail in terms
of uh research
so the first really refers to the
activity within work package two and
this is from
the work of professor bennett and dr dr
ian byron
and this is really looking at
pre-diagnostic aspirin use and mining
data from the national cancer registry
in ireland to identify
women who have taken low-dose aspirin
prior to breast cancer diagnosis and
then looking at impact of that
exposure to low-dose aspirin on their
outcome and also other different
parameters relevant to breast cancer
and as you can see here that if you look
at all breast cancers there seems to be
a significant if modest impact in terms
of aspirin on survival
is looking at breast cancer specific
survival across all breast cancer
patients but if you look more
specifically at patients which are node
negative
you have a very significant impact in
terms of a potential protective effect
of aspirin or a modifying effect of
aspirin and when taking pre-diagnosis to
breast cancer
dr o'driscoll published a paper recently
in cancer research on this very
interesting
protein neuron medium yew
and they identified this protein really
in initially in
cell line models which acquire
resistance to her2 targeted agents
they show that this
factor is increased in
cell lines which are resistant to those
types of agents
they also showed by using a particular
integrated resource that we developed in
our lab called breastmark where we
really assemble gene expression data
from
publicly available gene expression data
from
breast tumors where we have survival
data from
the patients
and we have data for example uh close to
four thousand individuals when we look
at expression of neuromed and u within
all breast cancer subtypes we showed a
high expression of mirror reading you is
associated with poor outcome at a very
significant level
then when dr o'driscoll's group actually
reduced the levels of this particular
protein within
a particular cell line models of breast
cancer by using a
short hairpin looped or an approach by
knocking down expression of that
particular factor she showed that she
could actually
decrease
both primary tumor growth but also
metastatic potential
another key factor is that when you
suppress
this particular factor you can actually
re-sensitize these what were resistant
cells to
her2 targeted therapies
the last paper i'm going to showcase is
really a work from a professor and leone
young and her group
in oncogene
and this is really comes a very
interesting concept that we know that
for example obviously there's two main
treatment options
used in breast cancer uh as i mentioned
previously we've got endocrine therapy
targeting patients which express the
eastern receptor or her2 targeted
therapies which overexpressed a her2
protein
and again
there seems to be some crosstalk between
these two different pathways
and this paper really tries to explain
this crosstalk in a bit more detail
and
from this paper it's seen that patients
which are her2 positive which have a
functional er pathway seem to have poor
outcome when treated with uh trastuzumab
and uh uh professor yong's group really
provided a pretty nice or kind of
mechanistic concept behind this
and it's known that for example if
patients are
which have an overexpression of the her2
receptor are treated with transducer map
you get modification of pr2 kinase
signaling and you get some kind of
signaling from pi3 kinase to the mic
gene
and what we've seen is that there is an
interplay there's an effect there's also
an effect in terms of um
when when you have an impact in terms of
pi2 kinase signaling there seems to be a
induction of
interactions between the eastern
receptor and this co-integrator protein
cbp
which can actually be and contribute to
enhanced transcriptional activity so in
summary when you treat with these types
of agents such as these hurt your
targeting agents like trastuzumab it may
actually
inadvertently lead to increased activity
in terms of decent receptor and
therefore contribute to
some kind of crosstalk scenarios
so where are we going forward with the
center
so again as i mentioned here we these
are the various different goals within
our center really our vision is
really to develop our uh
a vision beyond our fiverr uh timeline
as part of that we're really actively
focused on leveraging funding from
independent sources to accelerate
progress but also put in place a model
for beyond our program
our current program
but also more importantly we need to
make personalized medicine reality for
breast cancer patients
so again if if you're actually
interested in more details behind this
program i would encourage you to look at
this website
and you can also find our contact
details on on the website
so i certainly have time for questions
if there are some i i i'm not sure if i
was going to open up the q a box
i'll give a minute or two if there's any
questions if not
i can close it
so i don't think there's any questions
so i think we can probably close the
session
so thank